hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 16th of October and you're
watching GameSpot news Google has
unveiled the Nexus player an
entertainment device that plays games
and movies the Android powered micro
console has 8 gigabytes of internal
storage is powered by an Intel Atom
quad-core processor clocked at 1.8
gigahertz has one big bite of RAM and an
imagination power v of series 6 graphics
engine the operating system is called
Android TV and has movie apps like
Netflix YouTube and cooler it comes with
a custom remote but you can also buy
eight games controller separately for 40
bucks the console itself will run you
$99 and launches November 3 the Nexus
player will compete in the same space as
the Apple TV PlayStation TV and the
young CD Projekt RED have said that the
witcher 3 open world is what set to make
it far more immersive than previous
installments in the franchise The
Witcher dev have outlined that the
missing open-world element was
previously restricted by tech and last
gen consoles but that limitation is no
more The Witcher 3 game world is
purported to be 20% larger than that of
Skyrim in an interview with VG 24/7 they
said open-world was something we've
always wanted to do and we believe that
was the missing element for this story
to make it truly immersive we had to let
people explore it their way the trailer
for a game called hatred has been
released and it's sure to spark some
controversy the following footage is not
for those of you with a weak stomach so
if you're not into violence go on and
switch off the gameplay trailer for
hatred is among the most brutal combat
we've seen in a while probably because
it's pretty one-sided with the
protagonist claiming he hates everybody
before subsequently shooting up and
murdering innocent civilians the
isometric shooter comes from polish
developer destructive creations and
seems to revolve around you going on a
killing spree throughout New York taking
people out with not a whole lot of
persistence destructive creations have
said they don't want gameis to take this
one too seriously and just accept it as
a unique experience among a lot of games
they say a trending toward being polite
colorful and politically correct the dev
have said they want to give players pure
gaming pleasure that's your question of
the day let me know if you find this
kind of game refreshing or do you think
it's overly violent if you're after more
news we've got stories on driveclub
fixing its issues and Apple's new iPads
on GameSpot that is it for me today be
sure and leave me your thoughts and
check back same time tomorrow for my top
5 stories of the whole gaming week I
will see you then